[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là les chériis merci d'être
avec nous il est 19h42 bienvenue en
touche pas Mo et je dis l'heure parce
que nous sommes bien bien en direct yes
oui regardez tous les gens que vous
voyez là sont en direct ça veut dire
qu'ils sont là à l'instant T en même
temps tous les gens vous voyez là n'ont
rien d'autre à
donc forcément voilà c'est pas
c'est pas étonnant donc merci à vous
d'être là et bien entendu vous aimez
bien quand on fait le vendredi en direct
maintenant c'est tous les jours en
vendredi c'est en direct c'est c'est une
demande de
ma
mère et c'est important c'est important
euh les chériis ça fait longtemps qu'on
on avait pas vu notre chouchou Bertrand
DESC euh il revient d'une tri une
tournée capillaire
triumphale euh ce soir et en plus il a
fait un livre mon petit dictionnaire de
la royauté ah ouais bah il y a plein de
pages B lui il s'en fout plein plein les
poches il a bossé il a bossé il s'en
fout plein les poches alors j'ai pas le
livre he bien entendu j'ai pas non plus
voilà je voilà parce que je je travaille
et bah il va nous en parler mais pas pas
que parce que il y a il y a il y a des
problèmes entre Harry Méan et la famille
royale la guerre est relancée je sais
que ça vous passionne et Bertrand va
nous raconter ça Bertrand je peux le
voir merci je peux le voir on va voir la
PE cou voilà ah ouis ouais c'est chelou
mais c'est pas
mal chelou mais c'est pas mal allez
regarder le 14 novembre prochain le roi
Charles I fêtera ses 75
ans mais entre la série Netflix Darry et
Méane l'autobiographie explosive du
prince pleine de révélations et les
interviews à charge contre Buckingham la
tenstion entre le couple et le reste de
la famille royale est palpable vous
aviez dépensé suicidaire ouis c'était
très très clair et cette année le duc et
la duchesse de susex pourrai bien être
présent pour souffler les 75 bougies du
roi il n'y a pas eu de contact
concernant une invitation au prochain
anniversaire de Sa Majesté alors la
guerre entre Harry Méane et la famille
royale est relancé bertrandcker se fait
le point dans
TPMP
[Rires]
Bertran pas
mal inspection de la
Pecou qui j'imite per des Guer des Guer
qu'est-ce que tu as encore fait bah je
bah tu merdé mais tuarrêes pas de couper
tu tu te cherches oui je me perd je me
per perd tu te perds ah mon bébé allez
viens là viens dans mes
bras
ch une coupe
de qu'est-ce qui est beau chez toi
non c'est de l'autre côté l'autre côté
le
gauchee c'est la rate je dis
rate merci
Bertrand apparemment il y a du dans le
gaz tu rififi rififi pourquoi parce que
on est à 4 jours de l'anniversaire du
roi 75 ans pour ch le 3 Mar il fait quoi
il fait une roie ou pas il fait une so
ouais une roie ouais il fait une roie à
Londres à Londres ou il fait il fait
quoi il y a genre DJ tout il fait une
réception oui mais familiale et c'est à
peut-être à ce titre là que c'est
peut-être en encore plus vexant Harry et
man puisque il se dit que ils ont
attendu attendu attendu le carton
d'invitation dans leur petite boîte aux
LED de leur grande résidence à monit et
que le carton n'est jamais arrivé non j
c'est vrai tu es sûr qu'il y a pas eu
des problèmes de il y aurait peut-être
des problèmes de courrier non je ne
crois pas je crois que c'est volontaire
de la part attendsendss es en train de
me dire que Charles il a pas invité son
fils à son anive oui mais dis-moi c'est
dur c'est très dur frérot c'est violent
tu es surtout en train de dire qu'un
père envoie un carton d'invitation à son
mon fils il veut pas l'appeler comme
tout le monde il a raison
ouoc tu es sûr qu'il a pas appelé qu'il
va y aller
ou je suis sûr qu'il ne va pas y aller
quoi il va pas inviter Harry mais non
mais parce que la situation n'est pas
bonne elle est même à mon sens elle n'a
même jamais été aussi triste et aussi
pire on rappelle quand même triste comm
ça ton cheveux est
triste
tristés vous souvenez de ce scandale de
flogmore cottage on leur a demandé de
coter ce pavillon Schoun bien s FLM
cottage c'est un petit pavillon une
petite bicoque qui leur avait été pas
bicoque un petit pavillon qui leur avait
été donné par Elisabeth I au moment de
leur mariage qui comme cadeau Harry à
Harry et à Méane c'était leur piétateur
anglais londonien et bien Charles 3 vous
vous souvenez il a décidé de le
reprendre alors bon je ne suis pas du
tout pour défendre Harry et Méan par que
c'est vrai après le livre et tout ça de
la part de Charles 3 je pense qu'il
fallait vraiment redresser la barre et
vraiment montrer qu'il n'était pas
d'accord non moin ce qui me peine
fortement c'est qu'à l'heure où l'on se
parle shockmore cottage est encore
presque inoccupé il ne l'a pas il ne l'a
pas rendu ce qui veut donc dire que
c'était donc une volonté vraiment de
dire désormais les lias sont coupés et
on le voit encore plus avec le fait
qu'il y a cette réception qui est
organisée mardi et que il y a pas de
carton d'invitation qui a été lancé ça
n'engage que moi mais je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous lorsque vous donnez
un grand pour un anniversaire je trouve
ultra ch ça ton père il t'appelle mon
père il a fait son anniversaire chez
berb il m'a
appéis je conseiller t'envoyer un carton
mais tqu crois que mon père il m'envoie
un carton dans la gueule il vaenvoyer le
carton con de bouchece que tu
dis un con de ma bouche mais c'est elle
qui m' souffler bouche
bravo les clichés bravo les clichés que
mon père est tunisien il menvoie
des donc voilà donc s'il avait été s'il
était de cambré m'aa envoyé des
bêtises voilà donc voilà voilà tu aurais
très bien pu dire ton père t'a envoyé un
carton de
couscous bravo Jean-Michel mer bravo he
dit français cam c'est pas avec sens oui
bien sûr il de monter il m'a envoyé
quoi voilà bravo
monul
alors alors mais qu'est-ce que tu disais
est trop non il faut qu'il sorte là
bonsoir bonsoir qu'est-ce que tu veux
que ça va être pire encore parce que
pourquoi est-ce que Charles 3 fait ça
parce qu'il sait très bien ce qui va
arriver il se dit quand même que Megane
Markel maintenant elle est en train
d'écrire son
autobiographie c'est Darry à cartener
donc vous imaginez qu'il va encore y
avoir des aurores qui vont être lancé
comme cel public et surtout il y a on en
a parlé déjà ici le livre de mit Scoby
qui arrive novembreoby c'est le meilleur
pote
etan journaliste HID
Scob tout ce n' pas écrit tout que har
n'a pas osé dire oui ils sont c'est
quasiment le porteparole et son pote il
va balancer sur sur son père sur Charles
et surtout sur William il va balancer
quoi et ben devant que William est
tyrannique que il est intenable que
Charles I n'a aucune popularité que
voilà qu'il qu'il est très très loin
très qu'il n'est pas du tout en phase
avec son peuple par exemple c'est qui
Charles 1
Charles a il faut remonter très très
loin Charles
aou avant Charles I ah ouais ben normal
et fort fort Charles 2 c'est qui Charles
2 Charles 2 bah c'est il s'appelait
Charles il était le
2e bravo c'est dans le livre c'est dans
le livre livre mais et Harry c'est le 1
oui B il est pas rgant ouais et alors
c'est son vrai prénom c'est Henri non
Henri de Gal alors on l'appelle har se
présente parfois moi il se présente
comme Harry je vous présente je
m'appelle
henriain c'est
excellent alors et dis-moi non et
l'autre chose que je voulais peut-être
vous dire c'est que vous vous savez en
début de semaine il y a eu le concert de
Ketty Perry elle a fait oui
absn à Las Vegas elle a fait sa dernière
tournée un grand concert pour la fin de
sa résidence de
et souvous il de
K d'accord ouais c'est son deuxème nom
et vous souffv il y a eu cine Dion cine
Dion qui est d'ailleurs est apparu et
bien il y avait aussi Harry et Méan et à
nouveau toute la la presse tombe sur
Harry et Méane parce que ils ont été à
ce concert à bord d'un jet
privé oui alors que ils auraient
franchement pu faire le déplacement en
voiture ils étaient accompagnés de
greenet paltro quoi greenet paltro oui
greet palro voilà et alors c'est très
très très rencontré n pas miam sur ma
vie que c'est vrai éta dans le même
hôtel non mais vous l'avez crois discu
longts elle a voulu me parler ah oui lui
a dit ouais parce qu'en fait les gars de
l'hôtel lu ont dit oui il y a mec
elle est venue me voir j'étais
tranquillement sur mon TR il y aette PAL
qui vient me voir c'est elle qui est
venue à vous bien sûr elle vous a dit
quoi good
afternoon sûr que c'est gette pas trop
bien sûr g pas trop je te jure elle est
elle est très blanche ou elle est elle
est très mince elle avait un P noir
comme oui on a vu des photos non non
mais je vous jure que c'est vrai je l'ai
vu comme ça qu'elle
vous pourquoi elle cherch à vous
AB il était sur son transat et du coup
elle vouit juste le récupérer et du coup
il dit à tout le monde qui lui a parlé
là hor apparemment on a la fille
Jean-Michel
maisour non non non mais non mais non
mais on a rien faitang c'est parlé bien
sûr je vous AZ répondu en anglais vous
bien
sûr not my style
elle est magnifique
non pas magnifique du tout a dans non
mais non pas du
tout c'est vrai que croisé croisé à Las
Vegas on était dans le même hôtel la
Miami a 2
[Applaudissements]
secondes au
États-Unis je vous
jure qu é la tenur de l'échange moi
j'aimais bien comprendre pas échangé je
l'ai vu était dans le même hôtel que moi
d'accord elle est passé à côté
de
elle est pas sublime moi c'est pas du
tout dél pas votre V dél elle est diapan
oua ça va trèsà c'est c'est c'est très
très très très très actrice oui oui
surout c'était surtout de Katy Perry moi
que je parlais tout ça pour dire que
donc ils ont été au concert mais ils
n'ont pas été invités donc pourquoi se
sont-ils montrés parce que c'était le
concert auquel il fallait aller a invité
Dion elle n'a pas du tout
invité le billets tu vas me dire qu'
Harry Megan lui c'est le prince de
l'Angleterre celui-là hein il arrive il
s'incruste à une soirée frère il s
pasust ils ont
ach pourquoi parce que ctifer elle est
très très proche de Charles c'est
d'ailleurs une des seules stars
internationales qui a chanté le soir de
son couronnement au château K et Katy
Perry elle est très écologie elle est
très famille comme Céline Dion
d'ailleurs et vous pourrez remarquer
qu'il y a pas vraiment de cliché entre
Céline diillon et harryan ce qui veut
donc dire que alors ser je ne les aime
pas beaucoup mais il n'y a pas que moi
pas qui d'autre Aren Méan notamment cine
diillon c'est la chute de ta non non
mais c'est pas la chute de ma chronique
c'est pour vous dire que har Méan pour
l'instant quand même ils n'ont pas trop
[Applaudissements]
les il y a toujours des de séparation
s'il vous plaît c'est mon ami il y a des
rumeurs en effet que le l'ambiance ne
serait plus au beau fixe parce que lui
il lui dit il lui reproche
et l'autre on dirait qu'elle a un
coussin péteur
mais jamais vu quelqu'un roler comme ça
ouais alors oui et donc non mais mais
Harry reproche de plus en plus à Méane
ce côté vie à l'américaine et il lui dit
quand même de plus en plus que
l'Angleterre lui manque et qu'il
aimerait que ses enfants connaissent un
peu les Landes anglaises les chasses
vous savez tout ce qui fait un petit peu
la richesse de l'Angleterre le thé le
jein att c'est pour ça MEF elle va baser
ça sa meuf elle va le baser je ne dis
pas qu'ils sont au bord de la séparation
mais c'est vrai qu'apparemment il y a de
plus en plus d'eau dans le gaz il ne
supporte plus ce système de vie à
américaine il dit tu as fait de moi une
attraction har aurait ditela ouian il
était déjà une attraction en Angleterre
déjà mais oui mais sauf que il servit tu
m'énerves SAF que non parce que en
Angleterre il à Los Angeles à mon petite
colline qui est vraiment un genre de de
cité pour milliardes là-bas frais c'est
frais c'est frais c'est frais oui c'est
frais c'est beau c'est beau la propriété
c'est frais comme Hugo c'est c'est frais
comme h HUG frais
non elle est très
bonne non non mais pardon je je ne suis
pas au
niveau la maison ils ont acheté 14
millions 1300 m car 9 chambres 16
salalles de bains pourquoi laver toute
la journée mais il y a deux salles de
bain salle de bain pour Monsieur salle
de bain pour
madame on envoie des cartons
d'invitation et on partage pas la même
salle de bain non mais attends ils ont h
et h sales de bain chacun qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont faire ils ont deux salles de
bain une salle de bain chacun il se
croise pas en en se douchant ça bah
ouais tu ne partages pas ta sueur ah
ouais quoi ta sueur il vivrait plus
ensemble Bertrand elle elle elle a pris
un hôtel en face de son
agent
vraiment il a
vraim pasable
c'est contestable c'est contestable
parce qu'elle vient de signer un gros
contrat elle a besoin de voir son agent
et ses équipes c'est comme ça qu'elle le
défend en permanence mais dire vraiment
qu'ils sont séparés de corps Daniel je
trouve que c'est un peu fort mais en
tout cas en est vrai il y a de grosses
grosses tensions entre Harry etan ça on
peut vraiment
Laou il prend quelque fois une suite pas
très loin de leur grande maison mais il
dort tout seul par mais il a une maison
à 14 bar il va dormir dans cou non mais
il y a vraiment il est pas un peu feral
celui-à feral il pas un pe feral oui pas
ça veut dire quoi il est pas un peu oui
il est un peu
far il est pas un petit peu far il est
un peu
faral si sil venait à se séparer
qu'est-ce qui va se passer pour les
enfants parce que les enfants sont
anglais américains ouis c'estra ils sont
quoi ils sontis ils sont américain
puisquils sont non il ils sont
américains en effet serait vraiment
grosse problématique en tout cas vous
savez on l'a déjà avancé ici ellisabeth
II à l'époque elle s'est assuré que le
titre de duc de ce sexe n'avait été que
suspendu pas supprimé il pourrait donc
récupérer son titre et
récupérer auprès des autres Elisabeth I
ben si si un jour il vient y avoir une
reine ellisabeth elle portera le nom
d'éisabeth i le prochain roi ce sera
William et puis ce sera George donc pour
l'instanto moi le filsé George de Tunis
George de Tunis c'est le fils de William
et de on marque quoien c'est le fils de
et donc les autres les fils de Harry et
méanuxl ou il parce que pourquoi Harry
est le deuxème le second don il n'est
pas héritier du Trô non ce n'est pas un
truc de fou on est dans une famille
royale on n'est pas dans n'importe
quelle famille arrête c'est horrible
deuxème quoi l'autre il est roi et
l'autre il est quoi c'est un truc de fou
c'est un truc de fou et il sera rien ils
seront r jamais parce que ils ne sont
pas arrê arrête son hte il sont pas
héritiers donni quelque chose il peut
pas être sais pas moi c'est le CL le
plus fascinant du monde pas le plus
humain cy ah ouais c'est vrai oui ilque
totalementum et dis-moi Charles il kiffe
la D TR ou pas mais il kiffe d'être roi
écoute il a attendu tellement longtemps
ce serait difficile de pas kiffer
attendu bah 74 ans quoi depuis un an bah
depuis qu'il est né il a attendu tu
crois vraiment depuis qu'il est né il
savait qu'il était roi frère s que oui
depuis qu'il est né né frère il savait
même pas tu crois qu'on sait ce qu'on
est quand on est né et quoi non mais
après boutout quel ge oui mais bon à 3 4
ans
4 ans il il avait 4 ans lorsqu'éizabeth
2 a été couronnée en 1952 et depuis
qu'il a 4 ans il porte le titre de
prince de Gal et on lui dit que plus
tard lorsque Elisabeth ne sera plus là
ce sera à toi de Dir en quelque sorte
roi d'Angleterre de
Grande-Bretagne chef relig plus 70 ans
pour monter sur Trô tu es
constipé il avait
[Applaudissements]
non S et donc non mais c'est vrai que
c'est fou hein ce que tu racontes non
mais c'est fou parce que il a attendu
toute sa vie il sait très bien que ça
arrive trop tard il l'a dit lui-même et
qu'il aura un règne un règne écourté un
règne de passation qui va être celui le
grand règne qui a été ellisabeth I et le
prochain grand roi probablement qui qui
sera celui de William et en Angleterre
les spécialistes disent même que il
serait il va peut-être révolutionner le
système Royal il serait le premier roi à
abdiquer volontairement au bout d'un
certain moment quand il va considérer
que c'est for ne le porte plus
suffisamment au profit de Willam parce
qu'il sait très bien que l'image est
importante il ne règne voilà il ne règne
plus que par l'image aujourd'hui
absolument et k elle est sublime k elle
est sublime et k elle fera divinement le
job elle va venir rajignir tout ça cam
elle fait ce qu'elle peut mais la fin il
en a Mar il va dire
oui ils sont de partout en ce moment
c'est une catastrophe le règne de
Charles vient d'un
pique char qui Fa référ ouverture du
Parlement il y a eu des manifestants et
c'est vrai que ça ne s'était jamais
passé sous Élisabeth i le problème c'est
qu'il faut accepter de tout en non le
problème c'est qu'il faut accepter de
tourner cette
page qu'est-ce qu'il a qu'est-ce que tu
fais l'embê il veut pas que tu
[Musique]
reviennes ah il a dit oh non c'est vra
tuas pas tort bertr je suis d'accord
avec toi je suis de ton côté qu'est-ce
que tu veux dire j'ai une question sur
Harry il paraît qu'il a trompé mgan avec
une mannequin anglaise de 21 ans est-ce
que vous êtes au courant qui s'appelle
SAR al alors tu as des tu as des sources
que je n pas Sarah Anne min elle
s'appelle non je jure c'est vrai ouais
ce sera un char et lui il le sait pas
lui il veut pas dire SAR et cette
information j'ad sa de qui lui il a
roulé sa bosse he je t'explique non non
mais c'est la presse anglaise qui dit ça
ouais ouais qui est voilà il faut se
méfier aussi donc la presse l'a dit lui
il est pas au courant c'estï
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
anglais je suis belge je ne peux pas
avir B c'est insupportable euh c'est tu
peux nous raconter de trois anecdotes de
ton livre alors mon livre merci Cyril le
mon livre B voilà bah j'ai j'ai bossé
beaucoup sur ce Liv c'est un livre
cadeau de Noël j'ai a mis tout mon
corœps en tout cas et je propose au
lecteurs que ça intéresse et voilà 450
pages 450 pages et des illustrations je
me je vous emmène dans ma cour de
récréation à moi et je propose à celui
qui veut de venir jouer avec moi en
quelque sorte jouer au roi si l'on peut
dire et je me raconte moi je raconte la
liaison que moi j'ai avec ces grands
personnages Royau que j'ai toujours eu
et je leur écris des lettres voilà donc
j'ai écrit des lettres forcément à
Elisabeth 2 à Middleton Elisabeth 2 que
ce sera voilà que depuis qu'elle est
partie ce ne sera plus jamais la même
chose et que elle laisse l'institution
royale à force qu'elle a été trop
fabuleuse et force d'avoir été trop
fabuleuse elle met en péril une
institution tout
entière à Cam par
exemple ouiam j'ai direelle a faire tout
ce ve a bon blanchir ses dents TER ses
cheveux Massir en permanence elle ne
sera jamais à la hauteur de Diana elle
le sait très bien et
que elle sait elle en souffreem plus à
Mama elle sait elle en souffre c'est vra
Onon elle le sait elle en souffre elle
tirera toujoursana comme un bouleta plus
qu'elle fait des
yaourt tression
cheiment triste pour tu
saisent
dis on va se prendre les rosb dans la
gueule je vous le dis je connais à
Charles par exemple je lui dis que
pauvre Charles il n'a vraiment pas de
chance il a été écrasé toute sa vie
durant entre deux femmes sa mère qui est
légendaire et iconique et Diana qui est
aussi légendaire et iconique et Charles
les livres d'histoire ne retiendront pas
char il a que ses oreilles pour pleurer
mais il n'y a pas que l'Angleterre je
parle aussi de plein d'autres de je
pleore sur Charline de Monaco et
je j'adore le prince Alber
moi aussi j'adore al char et je dis que
Charline dans le fond étant nageuse de
la pque et elle a d tout elle a dû
renoncer à tout Charl accepter cette vie
différente avant d'épouser Albert Albert
et Charlen sont adorables c'est la
Principauté de Monaco qui est exécrable
festival non mais c'est vraiou c'est
très difficile pour Charlen c'est très
très difficile Albert fait vraiment tout
ce qu'il peut pour tenter de l'aider
mais la Principauté de Monaco pour c'est
le pire état du monde après celui du
c'est extraordinaire moi c'est mon rêve
d'habiter à Monaco oui peut-être mais
c'est très jaloux c'est très c'est un
territoire qui est rempli de
jaloux jalousie rocher c'est le rocher
làbas le rocher oui le rocher le blanc
rocherer blan évidemment grass Kelly
quand on parle de monacon on ne peut pas
ne pas évoquer grass Kelly qui été la
légende c'est grâce qui a fait naître
Monaco sans grâce il n'y aurait pas eu
Monaco il y a plein d'autres choses
voilà il
a mais tu as dit quoi encore d'Are dans
ton livre euh bah ple ch tuas dit quoi
Diana alors bah tu sais je me souviens
très bien j'étais devant mon écran
d'ordinateur et je me suis dit parce que
moi mon truc en plus Cyril c'est
d'apporter des petites anecdotes que les
gens n'ont pas forment je comment est-ce
que je vais encore pouvoir surprendre le
lecteur sur Diane surpr et ben il paraît
que j'ai réussi que j'ai fait et bien
dans mon récit quce que tu as fait dans
mon réit on est le 31 août 97 il est
minuit 19 la Mercedes elle vient de
pénétrer sous le le pont de l'ALEM sous
le tunnel de l'ALEM et elle en sort la
mercdè elle en sort et j'imagine ce que
Diana serait devenu si elle avait
Absolum et je pense que je suis pas très
loin quand même de ce andote alors c'est
de la fiction là pour le coup c'est la
fiction mais c'est un dictionnaire donc
je me suis permis toutes les audaces
vous nêtes pas obligé de lire ce livre
de A à Z toutes les fantaisies voilà
vous devez picorer entrer dans la danse
par où bon vous
[Applaudissements]
semble éc au Raspoutine j'ai écrit écr
sur Raspoutine a une boîte à Paris le
Raspoutine le rasp B j'ai pas écrit au
Raspoutine j'ai écrit sur
ras non c'est qui Raspoutine Raspoutine
en est en Russie sous Nicolas 2
l'héritier de l'Empire le couple
impérial n' fils Alexis le tsarevic
Alexis il est maître htier de toutes les
Russies mais c'est le Race Poutine qui
va aider à sauver l'héritier du TR c'est
conseill le conseiller derar de Russie
une particularité il avait un sexe
énorme et son sex été coupé mis dans du
formol et oné au musée de
Saint-Pétersbourg en
Russ
é il est il est tué par les bolchevies
il est enterré et lorsque l'on ressort
la dépouille 40 ans plus tard il n'a pas
bougé c'est quoi l'histoire pas bougé il
estque comme la
mi Patrick euh excuse-moi euh tu parles
de siss l'impératrice aussi oui si la
très belle et tu sais elle était très
forte auwi
non siss petite anecdote qu'est-ce que
j'ai fait sur Sissi tout le monde aussi
qui s'intéresse à la monarchie connait
Sissi et bien moi je raconte surtout la
mort de S elle est assassinée c'est une
des premières impératrices assassinée à
Genève au Beau Rivage sur lesqu du Beau
Rivage et qu'est-ce que j'ai découvert
dans mes recherche que les propriétaires
de l'hôtel du Beau Rivage lorsque
l'impératrice mort on est en
1896 encore propriétaire de l'hôtel
aujourd'hui c'est la mêmeç peruer CET
hôel donc je dis au lecteur si vous
aimez allez prendre en chocolat chaud
une tisane ou un café au bivage et vousz
sur les lieux même Dr d'cord il para que
tu parles de la pizza Marguerite
absolument la pizza margarita je parle
aussi bien de Vatel n
Pasi qu'est-ce
qu' c'est quo l'istoire de pizza Mar é
cré en de la Marguerite de Savo reine
d'Italie et pourquoi est-ce qu'elle est
blanche jaune et rouge puisque elle
évoque le drapeau italien blanche pour
la mozzarella rouge pour la crème
bolognaise ver pour le bas merci c'est
ouf ça quoi la pizza margarita c'est
pour une reine ou bah oui reine et la
reine la reine la reine et vaelle et la
reine je parle pas de la pizza la reine
il y a du ralouf dans la pizzarine je
mange pas et il y a Vatel par exemple
tout le monde estadé que Vatel a cr la
ch
non
Barb V qui s'est suicidé par V le mec de
Formule 1 Sébastien pas arrivé à temps
c'est qui Vatel Vatel c'est un cuisinier
il était le cuisinier de Louis XIV du
grand des princes de Condé absolument on
dit qu'il a inventé la chantille ce
n'est pas vrai du tout et il va se
suicider va-t-elle pourquoi parce qu'il
y a un grand dîner qui est organisé pour
Louis X et le poisson n'arrive pas
n'arrive pas n'arrive pas il sait qu'il
sera trop tard plutôt disgracié il
préfère quoi il a raté un poisson il
s'est
tué qu'il a pas fait Top Chef
[Rires]
celu imagin si à chaque fois que ma mère
elle brûait les boulettes et le tragique
de quo il a eu tellement une race il
attendait quoi il avent fait quoi comp
poisson un ton un ton complet ton
complet toi complet quoi complet mul il
avait de la tes cétait de l' de l'arr il
y avait
Slaten quoi il y avait de la SL quoi
mergest de quoi il avait devit faire un
poisson quoi une tranche de thon comme
ça oui oui alors c'était cétait des
buffets qui étaient somptueux on est au
château de Chantilly c'est le prage de
Condé qui reçoit li il a sur lui une
pression incroyable Gagou le traiteur
mais non le traiteur c'est Vatel
justement ah Vatel Gagou VAT Auguste
Vatel d'accord et il a raté un poisson
non le poisson pas il était où poiss il
était en chemin dis-moi le poisson il
est en voiture
frère on est en 1600 oui ils sont en
charrette et donc poisson il arrive pas
il a dit plutôt qu'être disgracié il
préfère se suicider jure c'est un
fousnehonneur qu' s'en fout frère le
poisson pire c'est que dans les 10
minutes plus tard le poisson AR poisson
oui mais oui mais Go est Mor
ils on mangé quand même
[Applaudissements]
poisson le gars le gars il s tué 10
minutes pour
les Peumo k le chef est qu Mme merci
très
intéressant